away from the Grandeur of Lords this is
where Cricket is already producing
Solutions on a pitch in style Bridge a
pathway being provided into the
professional game for British Asian
players in a system found to be Rife
with inequalities and discrimination
players who are questioning why there
are opportunities with County sides
prove so short-lived I think when you're
young and you're growing up from when
you're 10 to wherever when you're
playing Asia quicker you don't really
bat an eyelid at it that's kind of what
you brought up with and you think that's
just another one of those things but I
think the older you get you kind of
slowly start to realize that's not okay
before playing today they were all
digesting the cricket commission report
that's documented a deep-rooted racist
sexist and elitist culture in their
sport it's gone unchallenged too often
and can be hard to challenge it's hard
to bully a point what's the reasons why
people don't get opportunities but
there's always underlining factors where
before people were like nah it probably
doesn't exist but after the reports have
come out they clearly do we've got the
greatest series going on in the ashes
and it was just very unfortunate the
timing of this statement have come out
now when the second test starts tomorrow
but England led by Captain Ben Stokes
are committing to helping Cricket become
more inclusive
to the people involved in the game who
have been made to feel unwelcome or
unaccepted in the past I'm deeply sorry
to hear of your experiences qriket is a
game that needs to celebrate diversity
on all fronts because without diversity
this game would not be where it is at
today all while leveling gender pay
disparities to England's women can earn
a fifth of their male counterparts a pay
Gap the commission wants closing I think
the cricket now has to commit to change
so some of those structural issues we
were surprised to hear about including
the disparities in the way in which
women are treated the lack of investment
in the game albeit it's improved but
still a lack of investment women seen as
second-class Citizens disparity in pay
conditions Hospitality
England being crazy about Cricket
there's a mad rush of youngsters to
Lords to see Oxford and Cambridge pay
their annual match those from lower
socio-economic backgrounds can also be
treated like second-class citizens the
commission wants an end to elitist
advantages like this long-standing
annual games at Lords between Eaton and
Harrow and Oxford and Cambridge it's
places like here that provide the
solution to Cricket's diversity problem
the commission found that players might
have the talent but they often fall out
of the professional game the South Asian
Cricket Academy is providing a way back
in with a platform for players to
Showcase their skills against County
second elevens the fear will be players
are put off even seeking opportunities
in the sport after more than 80 percent
of British Asian respondents to the
commission reported facing
discrimination leveling the playing
field could take years with English
Cricket needing a reset after its racism
Reckoning Rob Harris Sky News
stourbridge